[Music]
how could a mountain of brawn
sell out taiwan wwe talent and movie
star john cena begged forgiveness for
calling taiwan a country
and not a wholly owned subsidiary of the
communist mainland in an interview
promoting the latest fast and furious
a film series about wasting gas cena
said
taiwan is the first country that can
watch f9 i had no idea there were f8s
that's a major boo-boo according to
beijing which goes after any public
mention of taiwan as an independent
nation even though the islands
but a self-governed democracy for 70
years
the kami's weren't having it thank god
cena stood up to them
in two languages looks like all those
body slams broke his backbone too
of course i didn't write that okay great
i didn't write that that was in a nut
that's one of our staff writers
i had nothing what you're crossing some
serious lines right here
i'm trying to keep it you know i'm
trying to keep it you know cool but you
watch your step with a little wrestling
job
i'm gonna come hold on like so let me
get to them finish this and then i'll
get to you
now worldwide china punishes
unflattering speech using political and
economic leverage
internally they use the lighter touch of
running you over with a tank
like other corporations who make big
bucks in china foreign studios gladly
look the other way despite the
documented human rights violations f9
took in nearly 136 million in china over
the weekend
enough to make even the most nimble
wrestler bend over on demand
okay great i i i warned him you all
heard me warn him right
but you think i could take john cena
take him what to lunch
[Laughter]
okay i thought i was the only well-built
man who could speak mandarin
under five feet yes after that you know
here's the thing first of all man john
cena is one of the nicest human beings
on the planet
and uh he's kidding he's getting a buck
do you think he's getting a bum rap on
this
yeah because it's here's the deal he
he's not stupid he's an extremely smart
businessman
and i'm sorry how much money was it
again greg 1336 million dollars
yeah uh saronara too bro i didn't say it
but i'm sorry for him
listen most movies today are made for
the chinese market
that's where the money's at so sorry
taiwan uh
whoops he made a mistake in an interview
and he cleaned it up he didn't just
clean it up
he said it in mandarin which loosely
translated is like look my bad you all
still buy my stuff won't happen again
tomato tomatoes state scones same thing
he made a marketing mistake that's why i
apologize because he's not
dumb like cena has been on the forefront
as far as working with
marketing and stuff it was years ago he
gave me great advice he said listen
the you need if you're gonna do movies
and stuff you really need to invest and
know what's going on in china you need
to know how it works and things like
that and second get a vasectomy
and um i didn't do either one
so thank god for that because you have
some people he's a great guy and you
guys are like
for people who don't know him and they
just see him as a really successful
attractive guy who does movies all
around the world he's also the same guy
who had to go to the bathroom
with 10 minutes to go at wrestlemania so
i can get my match in that's the type of
he didn't have to do that type of guy he
is so
relaxed a little bit he's a humble guy
and he just said he said state instead
of
you know not state country what do you
think david do you do
you align with tyrus don't let him
intimidate you i i
agree with him as of about 20 seconds
ago
no the the reality is that it's a fair
point that someone has a commercial
interest and there's sort of a line
that you want to walk there yeah i also
think taiwan has a lot of money
and i think that there's this
opportunity for someone it may not be
this moment and this person
for someone to come out on the other
side of it and not apologize
and open up a whole market in taiwan is
like the person willing to kind of say
the truth
it's unfortunate we're still in this
situation you remember the lebron james
thing and all the stuff the nba
a couple years back um look there's a
lot of money there there's a lot on the
line but
i do think at some point someone will
have to say the truth
not apologize and they'll end up making
money off of that
so here's what i think there's a couple
of thoughts we can hold at the same time
first
um we can't hold john cena to a standard
that the united states of america
doesn't live up to
the second as a man the only thing i
would criticize him for
is sort of the groveling nature of the
apology like he really meant
i'm sorry here and we know why to your
point tyrus because he wants to make
money
the difference between cena and lebron
though is that cena hasn't spent the
past decade preaching to the rest of us
about humanity and civil rights and
human rights totally contradicting
themselves on a moment's notice like
lebron did
but the big thing here is just how much
capital how much chinese dollars control
every single person's mouth and right
countries we will censor ourselves if
you pay the right price john cena or
anyone else and that's that's
terrifying we our culture is on their
payroll
yes i mean that's and and that's just
the way it is acting sports you name it
so cat this must be difficult for you as
a libertarian
that you know you're for free markets
and everything like that but there's
also some humanitarian concerns
libertarians you know well it's
difficult for me
because i just even in terms of written
word always confused john cena with
michael
sarah that is a confusion the male
lead in the coming-of-age dramedy juno
a terrible movie yeah well no i mean you
know not great but i i just i
i this is the first time i know what he
looks like i really thought
kind of maybe perhaps he didn't really
understand how he was even maybe being
controversial in the first thing he said
because otherwise i feel like it would
have been easy to dance around it he
could have just been like the people of
taiwan without mentioning the word
country like if you're dating a guy he
wants to you know clearly
is going to cheat on you but he thinks
lying would be a bridge too far
and he says like oh i'm going out to
dinner and they are picking me up at so
and so
without you so he doesn't have to say
she uh
he could have danced around it i don't
think he really i don't know but he
then to the groveling of the apology i
also think was didn't have to go that
far with that either i think it's
i'm also not making any money in china i
don't know what i would do if i was
offered something
you know what you would make make a
stand i'm sure
unless it's a lot of money then
everything she's in charge of
pairing people up cena and juno wow
wow michael said i don't know i don't
watch the wrestling
the wrestling all right
or the sports or the star wars i don't
pretend that i do
no you don't you're very consistent all
right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else